[Music]
it's time once again for the Oscars
Hollywood's annual award show for the
best films released between late
November and late December only one of
these nine films will win the coveted
title of best picture unless the guy in
charge of the result screws up because
he was on his phone backstage and they
accidentally give it to someone else
there's a mistake this is not a joke
moonlight has won Best Picture best
Oscars ever here are your nominees
you've seen done Kirk's breathless
portrayal of heroism in the face of
death now prepare for a movie about all
the talking that was going on at the
same time
stop interrupting me while I'm
interrupting you and get ready to see
Gary Oldman acting like you've never
seen him before in a fat suit hey I'll
take wearing a fat suit to win an Oscar
over eating a bison liver or something
really bad like being Casey Affleck
grumpy old man from visionary director
Guillermo del Toro who's contractually
obligated to be credited as visionary
director Guillermo del Toro comes a love
story between a woman and the fish
prisoner in her lab which sounds creepy
when you strip the art away from it but
trust me in the context of the story you
will totally be okay with this woman
having sex with a fish man it's actually
a really beautiful story about finding
your voice and oh man this is gonna be
known as the fish banging movie isn't it
the fish banging movie
said during the great Italian shirt
shortage of 1983 comes at touching
romance between this grown man and the
seventeen-year-old which also sounds
creepy when he stripped the art away
from it in this film full of lush
cinematography moving performances and
groundbreaking visual effects that
removed army hammers balls from his
short swords critics are saying it's
visually stunning transcendent and one
of the most mesmerizing films of the
year while the peach Farmers Association
is saying that's not why we grow them
but hey you do you low-heat a-- in the
sleepy town of ebbing missouri one
wronged mother will write injustice the
only way she knows how local advertising
in a film with such powerful
performances you'll stop referring to
Sam Rockwell as that guy and start
referring to him as that guy you know
from three billboards huh three racist
inside every Missouri you've seen him
play historical figures obsessed Mad Men
and Hawkeye nah not that one
the last the Mohicans guy that's the one
now witness Daniel day-lewis is stunning
farewell performance as an obsessed
craftsman who has trouble separating his
art from his personal life so Daniel
day-lewis some actor Method Man from
Greta Gerwig the talented actor director
so indie you've definitely pretended to
know about her already comes a note
perfect coming-of-age story about the
most difficult challenge a teenager can
face having to grow up in Sacramento I
want to go where culture in New York who
has such a tough time navigating her
friendships boyfriends and family you'll
almost forgive her for defending crash
by the Dave Matthews Band
we hate this song Who am I to talk I
listen to Papa Roach in high school put
a bird on it from the best director of
all time according to every anonymous
online metric comes a world war two
stories so visually beautiful so
clinically brutal and so needlessly out
of sequence it could only be made by
Christopher Nolan not everything has to
be a puzzle box Chris saving lots of
privates from two-time Academy Award
winning director Steven Spielberg the
Academy award-winning writer of
spotlight two-time Academy Award winner
Tom Hanks and twenty one time Academy
Award nominee Meryl Streep comes a
timely movie about the media resisting
an unpopular Republican president in a
film so calculated to win Oscars they
may as well have just put Academy Award
nominee in the title Academy Award
nominee the post from the production
company that's gone from the Teen Choice
Awards to the Academy Awards comes the
directing debut of the player formerly
known as Mouse cop and a horror thriller
that holds a mirror up to smug affluent
white progressives in other words the
Academy well it's an honor just to be
nominated right guys let the white ones
in starring the following comic book
movies the nerds that were snubbed in
the categories they should have been
nominated for thor ragnarok for best
gobloon Wonder Woman for Best two-thirds
of a movie Justice League for Best
Picture but only the Steiner card Logan
for Best Picture
for people who only sell comic book
movies last year guardians - for best
movie you enjoyed that immediately
forgot about spider-man homecoming for
best lack of an origin story and
guardians for best Russian superhero
movie I only saw a trailer for but holy
SH one of them turns into a bear and I
missed this one the Oscars
[Music]
man with all the sexual harassment
exposed this year this is gonna be a
really sensitive emotional ceremony
taking away hosts of the man show what
you guys excited about seeing a few
girls jump on trampolines Elon Musk is
short for elongated muskrat
my mom has a cat tootin teenage needle
toodles VHS the VH best I am the Batman
I am the Birdman now I am the vulture
and I'll never stop give up my dreams of
flying